Lionel nakche bonjour bonjour Maag pjou
vous êtes neurologue chercheur en
neurosciences cognitives alors ici on
s'intéresse à la question du vivant et
cette question du vivant aujourd'hui
centrale notamment évidemment en raison
de de la crise écologique et du
développement de l'écologie politique
pose d'emblé le problème de notre
rapport au monde très majoritairement
les philosophies du vivant ainsi que la
biologie semblent préférer une vision
continuiste et relationnel du vivant
nous appartenons au Grand Tout nous n'en
sommes qu'un chez nonom tout est
interconnecté tout est en tout enfin
c'est à peu près l'hypothèse Gaia je
simplifie mais ça n'est pas votre
position alors comment faire partie du
monde sans nécessairement s'y fondre hm
hm c'est c'est exactement la question
qui qui m'a inspiré dans ce ce nouveau
livre celle du rapport euh ce lien au
monde évidemment on fait partie du monde
mais du coup comment penser ce lien
notre appartenance et il m'a semblé
effectivement comme vous le soulignez
qu'on peut utiliser cette paire de
lunettes entre deux principes qui sont
en tension celui de la continuité et
pour plein de raisons sur lesquelles on
va peut-être revenir je crois que
intuitivement on a beaucoup de raison
d'aimer cette continuité et de penser
que les choses sont continues dans le
monde mais même en nous en réalité mais
en opposition ou en complément ou en
apposition à ce principe il y a celui de
la je la discrétion c'est pas son vrai
nom euh on pourrait parler de
discontinuité le fait que les choses
soient pas en continuité et qui est un
concept presque mathématique en fait
c'est le discret ou le continu et il m'a
semblé pour plein de raisons dont
certaines ont à voir avec mon activité
de neurologue et de chercheurs en
neurosci
que cette paire de lunettes tension
discret continue pouvait nous aider en
l'utilisant à repenser justement de
manière entre guillemets la plus
adéquate possible la meilleure façon en
tout cas une des manières de penser ce
lien au monde ça veut dire on voit tout
de suite les deux écueils d'un côté si
on on imagine que les choses sont
vraiment en discontinuité on voit
apparaître l'écueil de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une sorte de de d'égoïsme
radical on est totalement séparé rien ne
nous unit rien ne nous relie et cetera
et puis à l'inverse l'idée d'une fusion
totale en fait me semble tout autant
illusoire voire même dangereuse et
dangereuse par aussi vous savez les
effets de danger où on pense être dans
une sorte de de position généreuse mais
qui en fait était très narcissique donc
ça peut paraître un peu un peu compliqué
d'y résumer comme ça mais c'est cette
paire de lunettes là continue et et
discret et j'ai proposé d'appeler ça la
discrétion parce qu'en français on parle
de discontinuité mais si on fait
attention aux mots parler de
discontinuité ça veut dire qu'on va
définir le discret en né
parce que ce n'est pas de la continuité
alors je pense qu'on peut aussi
positivement le définir d'où cet usage
un peu néologique de la discrétion non
pas dans son sens psychologique habituel
mais dans cette idée de quelque chose
qui n'est pas en continuité alors
peut-être qu'on verra les les
implications politiques sociologique
justement de cette préférence pour le
continu mais déjà revenons aux assises
en fait de cette préférence erronée
illusoire du coup pour le continu et et
la façon dont fonctionne notre
conscience pour moi cette réflexion elle
s'est enracinée au début là-dedans c'est
je m'intéresse moi à la subjectivité à
la conscience avec le regard d'un
chercheur en neuroscience comment ça se
constitue comment est-ce qu'on perçoit
nous-même et cetera et euh un des
ingrédients principaux euh c'est ce
qu'on peut appeler une sorte de cinéma
intérieur vous savez au cinéma en fait
le le principe un peu magique du cinéma
quand vous êtes assis assis dans un
fauteuil c'est qu'on vous allez
percevoir subjectivement un film qui a
l'air continu pour nous c'est dire qu'on
a l'impression de voir tout le film
continue en réalité un personnage qui se
déplace un véhicule bon et en réalité ce
qu'on sait tous c'est que le truc
magique au cinéma c'est que sur l'écran
que vous observez on ne vous projette
pas un film mathématiquement continu
mais on envoie une une série discrète
d'images fixes donc une série d'images
discrètes le fameux 24 images secondes
mais ce que nous on perçoit c'est pas la
suite stroboscopique des images c'est du
continu autrement dit au cinéma on vous
envoie du discret et nous moulinons ça
en continu le film que nous percevons
autrement dit le film que nous percevons
d'une certaine manière c'est pas abusif
de dire que personne ne nous l'a montré
il s'est construit en nous avec déjà une
sorte de machine à construire les les
trous qui manquent donc entre deux
images qui semble se succéder notre
cerveau si on veut l'appeler comme ça
sans être finaliste produit en fait ce
qui n'a pas été à donné invente cette
continuité et là où cette histoire de
cinéma intérieur devient fantastique
c'est que cette histoire du mouliné du
discret en du continu c'est pas
seulement au cinéma que ça existe mais
dans la vie réelle donc même lorsque
nous nous voyons directement là et bien
d'une certaine manière mon cerveau et le
vôtre fait des sortes de captures à peu
près à 10 images secondes voilà tout ça
avec beaucoup de guillemets parce que
les images de notre pensée sont pas sont
plus complexes que celles du cinéma mais
en tout cas fait des saisies discrètes
et invente le le mouvement continue
autrement dit notre perception du
mouvement c'est déjà un film subjectif
elle invente ou elle synthétise est-ce
que notre conscience finalement c'est
une fonction de synthèse ah non c'est
plus c'est non c'est vraiment une
fonction de création elle va créer
quelque chose qui n'est pas là ah oui
vraiment alors une façon alors en plus
quand on joue avec le cinéma on peut
jouer avec les les références
cinématographiques tout le monde a vu
matrix matrix le film et je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais le personnage
qui va être initié à cette sorte de myth
de caverne contemporaine néo lorsqu'on
lui fait découvrir qu'en fait il vit
dans la matrice on lui dit ah il y a des
petits détails dans la matrice lorsqu'il
y a des déjà vécus je crois que c'est la
scène d'un petit chat et bien quand vous
voyez deux fois de suite le même chat
c'est qu'en fait il y a eu un bug dans
la matrice alors il y a l'équivalent au
cinéma c'est qu'au cinéma il y a une
illusion qu'on appelle l'illusion de la
roue qui tourne à l'envers vous avez vu
dans n'importe qu'elle filme des
diligences des voitures des vélos où
vous savez que le véhicule va dans un
certain sens et vous voyez les T les
roues qui tournent dans l'autre sens et
ce phénomène là au cinéma c'est facile
de l'expliquer parce qu'il dépend de la
vitesse de la roue et de
l'échantillonnage de la caméra et donc
parfois s'il y a deux positions qui
suivent le mouvement notre cerveau
invente entre les deux positions le film
continue mais si la roue va un peu trop
vite et qu'entre deux positions la
position l'image suivante donne un
mouvement de précession apparent parce
qu'en fait la roue a fait plus d'un
demi-tour et bien votre machine à
inventer le mouvement elle va inventer
la direction dans l'autre sens donc ça
c'est facile à comprendre mais là où ça
devient intéressant c'est que même quand
vous n'êtes pas au cinéma la prochaine
fois vous êtes sur le périf en voiture
si si vous êtes en voiture et bien vous
verrez que dans la vraie vie on voit
aussi des roues qui tournent à l'envers
ce qui veut dire que cette fois-ci c'est
pas parce qu'on nous a montré des roues
des images fixes c'est parce que
nous-même nous fonctionnons comme ça
donc c'est vraiment une création une
fonction non pas de synthèse on remplit
les trous on invente ce qu'on a pas vu
en fait d'une manière beaucoup plus
générale que ce que je viens de dire
mais là c'est un exemple ouais c'est
enfin c'est assez fascinant mais du coup
ça expliquerait la propension à croire
le monde continu enfin si exactement
c'est que je crois qu'on a une une sorte
notre alors tout ça on peut ensuite en
en en biologie en neurosciences il y a
parfois évidemment une recherche du sens
pourquoi est-ce que notre machinerie
biologique a évolué comme ça alors on
peut imaginer plein de raisons en en
évolution darwinienne de se dire par
exemple que évidemment c'est plus simple
que notre cerveau ne traite qu'une
portion Lim limité de la réalité c'est
parce que s'il devait traiter en temps
réel tout ça c'est impossible donc il
serait toujours en retard sur le réel ça
demanderait des capacités plus
importantes première réponse deuxième
réponse plus intéressante c'est que le
fait que nous produisions quelque chose
que nous n'avons pas perçu ça veut dire
qu'on arrive dans une dimension
projective de l'esprit c'est notre
esprit n'est pas là pour recevoir ou
comme vous le disiez synthétiser mais
pour produire et donc presque pour être
en avance donc pour être en avance sur
la réalité pouvoir penser ou faire
advenir des choses qui n'existent pas
encore pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
donc on peut imaginer pourquoi nos nos
systèmes disons biologiques ont évolué
comme ça mais là et je rebondis sur ce
que vous disiez où ça devient fascinant
c'est qu'effectivement le fait de savoir
que nous fonctionnons comme ça ça nous
permet de de d'éclairer un peu cette
propension à imaginer les choses
continues donc dans plein dans plein
d'éléments on imagine que l'espace est
continu au sens mathématique alors que
si vous discutez avec des physiciens ce
dont je ne suis pas et bien vous verrez
que c'est un débat évidemment immémorial
mais aujourd'hui très contemporain
est-ce que la matière est-ce que
l'espace lui-même est discret ou continu
naturellement on l'intuitionne comme
comme continu et le temps aussi notre
introspection du temps est très souvent
une sorte de temps continu non seulement
le temps du monde mais également notre
temps à nous c'est que lque souvent
lorsque l'on pense à celui ou à celle
qu'on a été il y a un an il y a 6 mois
il y a 30 ans on s'imagine souvent dans
une continuité de ça donc comme vous le
disiez je pense que d'un point de vue
donc caméra subjective de l'individu le
continu domine parce que pour plein de
raison on rend continu des choses qui ne
le sont pas ou dont n'avons pas
directement des
connaissances continues donc on produit
du continu et comme vous le disiez je
pense que c'est un des facteurs un des
moteurs qui lorsque l'on pense la
question du lien au monde au reste du
monde que nous les autres humains le
reste du monde non humain la nature dans
son ensemble l'univers et bien on a
peut-être cette propension guidée par
cette intuition immémoriale de mouliner
du discret en du continu d'imaginer que
notre lien c'est un lien de continuité
et là je pense que voilà là où ça
devient intéressant c'est qu'on a pas
mal de raisons de penser que c'est pas
c'est pas continu je pense que c'est pas
continu on peut montrer que ce principe
de discrétion de discontinuité il est au
cœur de du fonctionnement de notre
esprit notre cerveau et que le fait de
le savoir peut nous aider à repenser ces
questions en tout cas ça ça requestionne
la place du sujet exactement ouais et
d'ailleurs pour pour interroger cette
position de sujet vous convoquez deux
philosophes un petit peu pour peut-être
pour polariser de deux grandes positions
que sont des cartes revenir un petit peu
là oui alors en plus ce livre ça m'a
beaucoup amusé de l'écrire comme ça
c'est que je l'ai écrit il a la forme de
L'Éthique de Spinoza donc c'est une
liste de proposition de scolis d'axiome
pour lui donner une structure discrète
une structure de où justement la
discontinuité du langage et pour moi
c'était un élément fondamental c'est
qu'effectivement alors sont des
philosophes déjà même S sont des pH de
la modernité qui peuvent paraître assez
anciens mais qui sont au cœur pour moi
de cette question enfin ils inaugurent
quand même la la modernité exactement
ils inaugurent cette moderné et je pense
qu'on en est on est vraiment au cœur de
ça alors pourquoi c'est deux parce
qu'effectivement d'un côté en tout cas
c'est ma lecture de ces philosophes
c'est que descart euh qui va vraiment
poser le sujet de dire sens de
subjectivité euh qui en se posant cette
question à partir d'où on pense de se
rendre compte que croire pouvoir sortir
de soi il y a quelque chose d'illusoire
donc je suis enfermé dans ma citadèle
subjective comment je fais pour essayer
de de de gérer cette question et tout
commence par le sujet le pour moi ma ma
compréhension du du du cogito du je
pense donc je suis c'est vraiment euh
commencer par ça commencer par ne jamais
sortir ou en tout cas pour viser au-delà
de soi de ne pas oublier que on pense
toujours à travers soi avec évidemment
comme leçon philosophique pour moi
l'idée que croire pouvoir sortir de soi
c'est pour moi une gageure et souvent
euh une sorte de piège dans lequel on
voit bien que l'écueil c'est de penser
être sorti de soi alors qu'on nen est
jamais vraiment sorti et donc du coup
pouvoir croire avoir accédé à ce continu
dans lequel on bagnerait tous mais qui
une sorte que que mon nbril élargit sur
qui se projette sur le monde et en toute
bonne conscience et alors Spinoza en
face parce qu'évidemment Spinoza le fait
de dire je sors de moi il y a une
substance et que cette substance qui se
décline avec ces deux attribut quoi
spinoa et de dire qu'en fait là le monde
se pense comme une chose comme une une
substance infinie dont nous faisons tous
partie donc voilà descart et Spinoza
alors les deux sont au cœur de ce livre
ça penseche plus vers Descartes pour
l'aspect très bien discret mais voilà
Spinoza n'est jamais très loin non plus
c'est bien de réhabiliter un peu des
cartes par les temps qui court pas B al
peut-être vous avez raison ouais oui
alors c'est vrai parce que bon il y a a
il y a aussi des évidemment beaucoup de
de choses qu'on peut questionner mais en
tout cas j'aime bien l'humilité en fait
j'aime bien l'humilité de je parle pas
en général mais mais de descart j'aime
bien cette idée euh de que quand vous
réalisez que que tout ce que vous pensez
qu'en tant que vous êtes conscient euh
vous le pensez à partir de ce point
d'objet d'observation sur vous-même et
sur le monde dont vous pouvez pas sortir
euh j'aime bien cette figure là en fait
alors ça des implications politiques ça
a des implications éthiques même puisque
cette position du sujet euh va euh vous
amener à repenser le rapport à l'autre
et le rapport au collectif oui
absolument avec l'idée que le principe
qui se dégage alors peut-être l'éthique
que j'essaie de dégager c'est une une
éthique dans lesquell on on commence à
chaque fois par prendre conscience de
notre discrétion c'estàd que je ne suis
pas vous vous n'êtes pas moi je ne suis
pas la nature le reste de la nature je
ne suis pas un fleuve je suis pas une
forêt donc une première étape qui est
une prise de conscience de ce que
j'appelle la discrétion
individuelle et et là aussi que le
curseur c'est c'est l'individu c'est la
conscience individuelle avec l'idée donc
que dès lors que pour différentes
raisons il y a des forces ou des
mouvements ou des tendances qui font qui
veulent déplacer le curseur soit au-delà
du sujet dans des communautés dans des
groupes quel que soit le critère quelle
que soit la cause pour lequelle on veut
le faire les causes religieuses
politique quel qu'elle soit dès lors
qu'on perd le sujet ou qu'on entre
guillemets qu'on sacrifie le sujet
l'individu dans cette éthique là ça
fonctionne pas en tout cas celle que je
propose mais on a aussi on peut déplacer
le curseur aussi en infra en infra sujet
dans certaines formes d'écologie
politique un peu radical on peut se dire
en fait nous sommes tous constitués de
matériaux biologiqu le sujet c'est une
structure éphémère subjective avec toute
son son son narcissisme étriqué et un
peu et donc on peut essayer de déplacer
le curseur aussi en bas donc cette
éthique que je propose elle a un cap
fixe qui est le sujet en fait c'est
l'individu conscient et à partir de là
il y a deux temps le premier temps qui
est à chaque fois de reprendre
conscience de notre lorsqu'on a une
question à se poser de cette discrétion
fondamentale du sujet et ensuite il y a
un deuxième temps qu'on n'est pas obligé
de faire qui est optionnel et qui
demande de l'engagement qui la lucidité
et puis aussi moi j'aime bien du panache
vraiment c'est de dire sachant que je
suis discret je vais oser ce que
j'appelle le comci de continuité c'est
que je ne vais pas croire que je suis en
continuité avec le reste du monde mais
je vais considérer que je suis dans ce
comme-ci non pas une simulation du
mensonge mais une simulation de la
volonté je décide en toute connaissance
de cause et ce panage parce qu'il y a un
peu de ridicule c'est pas comme ça que
nous sommes mais je vais faire comme ça
je faire je m'engage dans ce commeci de
continuité pour penser le lien avec le
reste du monde et au passage de manière
tout à fait simple on peut se rendre
compte que la meilleure façon de penser
vraiment le lien à quelqu'un ou à
quelque chose qui n'est pas vous c'est
de commencer par prendre conscience de
la la la discontinuité de la séparation
si vraiment on imagine qu'on est dans un
grand tout la notion de lien n'a même
plus de sens vous n'avez plus besoin
d'être en lien avec vous-même en fait
donc le la séparation en fait est la
condition même première de valoriser le
lien sinon il y a pas vraiment d'idée de
lien donc c'est c'est ça l'appareil
auquel j'aboutis et effectivement on
peut ensuite l'utiliser pour l'éclairer
sur les grandes questions contemporaines
sur les toutes les luttes progressistes
sur les questions de fin de vie
précisément sur la question de la fin de
vie par exemple alors sur la fin de vie
en fait il y a il y a y a il y a deux
aspects il y a il y a un aspect que je
traite pas beaucoup dans ce livre qui
est disons l'aspect législatif par
exemple est-ce qu' on va vers une loi
qui changerait au-delà de la loi cl
Leonetti de dire donc il y a une
dimension législative qui à vrai dire
m'intéresse peu vous l'avez rappelé je
suis médecin donc j'ai un rapport aussi
de avec les patients l'inquiétude
première que j'ai dans l'idée d'une
évolution législative sur la fin de vie
elle se ramène à un principe pour moi un
risque qui est le risque qu'on pourrait
appeler le risque normatif le risque de
considérer que si euh dans une situation
donnée pathologique la majorité des gens
choisissent ça alors ce patient ou cet
homme ou cette femme qui est en
situation dans son histoire à lui ou à
elle fait qu'à un moment donné euh
confronté à cette situation de grande
fragilité euh s'engage dans un chemin ou
dans l'autre euh qu'il puisse y avoir du
coup une influence sur le cette sorte de
de pouvoir d'autonomie du sujet euh
guidé par des principes normatifs en
gros une société qui d'une manière ou
d'autre ben vous savez dans 95 % les
gens dans votre état ils font ça donc
donc c'est le seul élément maintenant
pour la question dont vous parliez sur
ce ce principe c'est ça rebondi sur sur
le lien que nous avons avec nous-mêmes
et c'est de bien prendre conscience du
fait que effectivement non seulement je
suis en discontinuité avec le reste du
monde mais aussi avec celui que j'ai été
dans le temps ce qui veut dire qu'à
chaque instant je suis comme une sorte
de saingleton vous savez ces ensembles à
un seul élément qui du du haut de ma
subjectivité ici et maintenant pense
quelque chose et on est à chaque fois
là-dedans donc c'est c'est très
important mais pour autant de garder à
l'esprit pr cette discrétion de nous
avec nous-même il est pas nécessaire que
je reste en accord avec celui que je
suis maintenant à l'instant ou au moment
suivant au moment précédent et donc de
là j'en tire pas un principe univoque
mais juste ce rappel cette lucidité de
se dire ce que je crois vouloir ici et
maintenant ça s'applique pour ici et
maintenant mais si je décide de
l'appliquer à celui que je serais et
cetera bien il y a une forme de violence
de soi à soi il veut pas et parfois il
faut être violent sans doute dans mais
simplement de le savoir de le faire en
toute connaissance de cause et dans la
vraie vie il m'est arrivé je pense comme
beaucoup de collègues médecins ou dans
la vraie vie de tout le monde de voir
tous les cas de figure il m'est arrivé
de voir quelqu'un qui s'était tout qui
s'était arrangé pour vraiment pouvoir en
toute connaissance de cause pouvoir
mettre fin à séjours s'il était en perte
d'autonomie importante je pas donner les
détails et en fait qui une fois qu'il
arrive dans cette situation veut vivre
et vous voyez l'inverse une fois de plus
c'est pas oui oui bien sûr que la
continuité à soi-même et là aussi de
l'ORD d'une production permanente quoi
exactement elle permanente et là les
neurosciences contemporaines ou cette
activité de clinicien de
neuropsychologie est une fenêtre mais on
a aussi beaucoup d'autres fenêtre moi
j'aime bien citer souvent des des des
exemples littéraires celui qui un de
ceux qui m'avait le plus marqué c'est de
dans la recherche prou quand il y a le
volume où où Albertine s'en va Albertine
disparu il y a ce petit passage où le
narrateur se rend compte qu'en fait il
est habité par une multiplicité de
lui-même de soi qui à chaque instant le
moment où il s'assoit sur un fauteuil le
moment où il met ses pieds dans des dans
dans dans dans des chaussons le moment
où il va chez le coiffeur il a il vit
l'expérience qu'à chaque fois celui ce
moi qu' est à ce moment-là apprend comme
si c'était pour la première fois le
départ d'Albertine nous sommes habités
par une multiplicité de d'individus qui
sont pas simultanés mais qui à Cha
instant semble être en discontinuité
donc on trouve ces idées j'ai cité ce
passage là mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres donc simplement ce qu'il y a
c'est qu'on peut donner une incarnation
aujourd'hui à cette idée heureusement la
question de de la métaphore pour passer
d'un point de vue à un autre passer de
de V are spécialité des certaines
pathologies neurologique à un état des
lieux du collectif alors je sais pas
prenons une pathologie que sur laquelle
vous auriez travaillé je sais pas que ce
soit c'est d'ailleurs souvent des
pathologies
discontinuistes la schizophrénie ou
ouais vous avez raison alors il y a en
fait peut-être deux points de départ
fondamentaux c'est que quand vous faites
de la neurologie et notamment la
neurologie de la pensée des émotions des
comportements ce qu'on appelle la
neuropsychologie ouis cette dimension là
not discipline qui a à peu près 250 ans
quelque chose comme ça moderne elle est
marquée par le principe de dissociation
c'est qu'en gros derrière l'unicité et
la continuité apparente d'une fonction
mentale donnée le langage la mémoire la
conscience en fait les troubles de ces
fonctions provoqué par des lésions du
cerveau ou des dysfonctionnements du
cerveau vont nous révéler chez des
malades une discontinuité une
multiplicité une sorte de mécano de de
de choses qui lorsqu'elles sont
dissociées on voit que ce sont pas les
mêmes mais par que tout va bien elle on
le voit pas exactement on le voit pas
mais elle continue à rester différente
c'est exactement ça et et c'est ça la
valeur ajoutée de notre discipline c'est
que quand vous êtes neurologue et aussi
psychiatre que vous vous intéressez à
ces pathologies avant tout vous
intéressez au patients pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'ils ont les aidés
vraiment comme tout le reste de la
médecine et en plus c'est pas un met et
en plus il s'avère qu' avec cet effet
entre guillemets sans aspect péjoratif
évidemment mais l'aspect caricaturant
que provoque sur notre fonctionnement
esppect de révélateur on découvre des
choses qu'on aurait pas imaginé
autrement en tout cas beaucoup plus
difficilement pour vous donner un
exemple quand on découvre fin 19e début
20e que des patients massivement
amnésiques qui peuvent plus fixer un
nouveau souvenir conscient ce qu'on
appelle la mémoire épisodique sont
néanmoins capable de mémoriser
inconsciemment plein d'autres choses des
souvenirs perceptifs moteurs olfactif
des apprentissages on découvre et c'est
la version contemporaine que derrière la
mémoire au singulier on a une
multiplicité une douzaine de mémoires
différentes qui cohabite donc tout ça
pour vous dire que ce qui peut paraître
comme une marotte ou une sorte
d'obsession de la discontinuité quand
vous rentrez dans la mécanique de la
pensée du cerveau tout est discontinu et
que la continuité c'est le fruit d'une
sorte d'unification qui produit cette
impression de continuité du monde mais
aussi de nous mais que le facteur
premier le niveau premier est plutôt à
voir du côté de la discontinuité et vous
le disiez la schizophrénie c'est un
exemple le premier symptôme de la
schizophrénie ce qu'on appelle la
dissociation et même schizophrénie c'est
la dissociation vraiment de l'esprit et
bien VI là c'est justement d'une
certaine manière on pourrait dire une
une faillite par la pathologie
psychiatrique d'assurer chez le sujet
cette continuité donc on a besoin que ça
continue on a besoin pour exister pour
faire sens à nous-même d'avoir une
certaine notion de continuité c'est pour
ça que alors parfois on me dit oui ton
livbre s'appelle l'apologie de la
discrétion
mais alors je ne mets pas la continuité
au placard oui parce que sinon
effectivement on en reste dans une forme
de pathologie ou exctement on peut plus
faire articul
de de forme de mémoire exactement et
puis dans une version disons éthique je
pense que c je je le développe que ce
principe radical de la discrétion c'est
une forme d'égoïsme radicale au sens au
sens c'est rien de péjoratif c'est
descriptif c'est que si on s'engage sur
une discrétion radicale on est déjà
égoïste avec nous-même donc on peut
l'être que on peut être que égoïsteve
avec les autres et c'est alors c'est
c'est une éthique ou une morale comme on
veut mais c'est descriptif ce que je
veux dire autrement dit apologie de la
tion mais derrière il y a cette tension
je pense qu'on est en permanence on a
besoin des deux principes du discontinu
et du continu l'acte de naissance des
neurosciences contemporainees c'est un
prix Nobel en 1906 quand un chercheur
espagnol ramonaral très connu dans notre
domaine découvre que les neurones que
tout le monde connaît de nom et bien les
neurones au niveau de leur contact c'est
son son expression à lui ils
entretiennent des relations de contigué
et pas de continuité et ça c'est l'acte
de naissance de la discrétion neuronale
on pourrait dire il a le prix Nobel pour
ça et la même année le deuxième
chercheur qui est le prix Nobel comme
lui il s'appelait Camilio Golgi un
immense chercheur italien mais qui lui
pensait que le cerveau était continu et
il a eu le prix Nobel parce que il a
inventé la technique que Caral a utilisé
pour contredire pour démontrer l'inverse
exactement et donc il y a un côté un peu
vous savez l'émission de Jacques Martin
là un peu où tout le monde a 20 à la fin
c'est dire qu'en gros les deux ont le
prix Nobel en même temps mais si vous
lisez ça raconte bien la tension entre
les deux principes qui continuent de de
jouer et de de structurement exactement
et donc il y a un aspect analogique ou
métaphorique mais dans lequel on est
toujours là projeter ces questions sur
sur les débats contemporains par exemple
là aussi je prends des exemples de
mouvements de de lutte pour par exemple
contre des discriminations ethniqu
religieuse social évidemment que la
lutte contre les discriminations non
seulement il y a rien à dire mais il
faut lutter contre les discrimination
maintenant c'est la les moyens de cette
lutte et que je pense que chaque fois
que cette lutte va pouvoir justifier le
fait de déplacer le curseur au-delà de
cet élément individuel discret qui n'est
pas en continuité avec les autres là ça
pose pour moi problème le fait
d'imaginer qu'on puisse interdire ou
censurer qui je prends C exemple parce
qu'il existe qu'une poétesse
néerlandaise homosexuelle blanche
traduise une poétesse américaine noire
et bien qu'on dise non parce que vous
n'êtes pas de la même pour moi c'est un
problème c'est un problème au sens où où
faire ça c'est d'abord empêcher euh
cette décision discrète individuelle de
dire où que je sois né qui que je sois
quelle que soit mon identité c'est mon
genre si je décide d'incarner ou de
m'associer à telle lutte je dois pouvoir
le faire voilà et que inversement le
deuxième effet pervers c'est que
d'imaginer que seul je prends cet
exemple d'Amanda Gorman qui a écrit ce
poème à l'époque de d'Obama l'idée qu'il
faudrait que la traductrice dans ce
poème partage des critères collectifs
qui associent la poétesse à ces
traducteurs ça donne aussi implicitement
l'idée qu'en fait les femmes
hétérosexuelles noir sont dans une
continuité sont toutes les mêmes absurde
et que donc une fois de plus ce curseur
c'est de dire euh pour toutes ces luttes
là je pense qu'il faut concentrer mettre
en avant que le premier niveau de valeur
indépassable c'est l'individu conscient
discret et que ensuite à partir de là on
fait des comm si de continuité avec
différents principes donc voilà c'est un
peu ça ce que la déclinaison de cette
éthique l'individu comme condition de
possibilité dansun collectif et non pas
pour l'individualisme à tout craint
parce que le libéralisme dites-vous est
aussi une forme de continuisme ah oui
exactement c'est étonnant un des points
qui était moteur pour pour moi c'est que
euh euh notre fils estîné Nathan en fait
quand j'étais depuis 2 ans dans cette
aventure m'a dit mais est-ce que tu as
lu la la thèse de Marx la thèse du jeune
Marx et qui était une thèse sur
l'atomisme de Démocrite et Épicure qui
est un texte assez court et ça tombait
pour moi comme une révélation de se dire
qu'en fait cette histoire de discret
parce que les atomes c'est ça est-ce que
la matière c'est des atomes les atomes
qu'est-ce que c'est donc qu-ce qu'il y a
des entités discrètees fondamental et
que cette résonnance est pas uniquement
sur la matière c'est sur les individus
sur les consciences l'individu et le
collectif donc de voir que cette paire
de lunettes discret continue j'étais pas
du tout le premier à l'utiliser pour
penser le lien entre l'individu et le
collectif et que ça pouvit avoir des
portées fondamental ah oui donc si Marx
l'avait fait donc voilà c'est ça sur les
épaules de géant et que du coup ça veut
dire aussi que que cette questionl euh
lorsqu'on on commence à jouer avec elle
elle est fcinante parce qu'elle est
complexe c'estàdire que vous commencez
par vous en emparer très souvent les
gens vont dire oui pour moi le plus
important c'est l'individu vous soyez de
gauche de droite la plupart des discours
vont perdre en cours de route cet aspect
là pour des raisons
de le but ultime d'une lutte politique
alors effectivement comme vous le disiez
dans le libéralisme dans mais aussi dans
des pensées d'extrêmees gauche en fait
il y a parfois un point commun une sorte
de méta invariance où vous avez parfois
vous perdez le sujet quoi où en fin de
compte c'est plus l'individu qui compte
c'est l'humanité mais l'humanité pour
moi elle peut exister que s'il y a une
collection de sujets et avec l'idée que
c'est pas parce que nous sommes séparés
que nous ne faisons pas ensemble c'est
il existe desensme la condition de
possibilité d'être ensemble c'est
d'abord d'être séparé exactement merci
beaucoup l Nache merci beaucoup ping